hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled
want to know if your cannabis is safe
i'm susie valdez of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
sponsored by
agilent so let's get started before we
begin i want to remind everyone that
this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions
as you want during the presentation to
do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and if you
can
address each question to the specific
speaker
and then click send we will answer as
many questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
click on that ask a question box located
on the far left
of your screen i now present today's
speakers
dr anthony martirone senior scientist
and cannabis technical lead at agilent
technologies
and visiting professor at john hopkins
university school of medicine
joining him is timothy boldick lcms
application scientist at agilent
technologies
for complete biography on dr anthony
macharone and timothy boldick
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
anthony you may now begin your
presentation
welcome to both of you
well thank you uh and today we'd like to
briefly
cover some of the things that i've been
doing in the canvas world
for cannabis testing regulatory testing
a lot of this material
certainly applies to hemp as well and my
colleague
tim and i'm going to present some
material i'm going to quickly go through
just the top-level review of all the
latest and greatest applications that
agilent has put out there
and tim's going to focus more on the
e-method section
and what that means for you our
customers
so before we get started i have to make
a disclaimer
that agilent products and solutions are
intended for use
where this is permitted by law you know
in
quality control and safety testing
laboratories
okay as a quick introduction uh
safety quality testing necessitates a
suite of analytical
systems uh the chromatographic
spectrometry
real-time pcr all these tools are needed
to be successful
uh when you're testing cannabis or hemp
and agile has developed a suite of these
e methods
which essentially assembles the
application
uh the consumables uh and everything
that's needed to be successful
gets you most of the way there uh and
just by loading this onto your system
and off you go
and it defines the instruments the
consumables stable prep data acquisition
data analysis reporting tools all of
those things that you need
uh for the for the method uh there's
simple client side tools
essentially you download them there's a
little software package or application
that you unzip it it loads the methods
where they need to go loads of the
sequences where they need to go
puts everything in the right place and
you're pretty much ready to go from
there
with just a little bit of help from an
azure consultant
the consumables kits the cannabis
consumable
kits bundle all of them together
cannabis as we call them
very specific for those methods potency
the column reagents etc are part of it
pesticides
columns for both gas phase and liquid
phase and
sample prep tools to do about 400
samples already ready to go right out of
the box
so tim will talk a little bit more about
that
um but it really supports you know the
agile portfolio supports the entire
cannabis
testing workflow all the required
applications
um you know rugged platforms hplc
lcm sms gcm sms gcms
all of these tools can be implemented in
the laboratory
most of these operate on mass hunter so
one
software for your entire laboratory you
don't have to have
every instrument has a different
software that you have to learn
primarily it's all mass hunter
fully developed workflows what i talk
about a workflow i mean
from sample prep to reporting everything
you need
from there to get the job done get a
billable out the door
and of course our customer support and
service we've been heavily engaged in
this
market now for several years and
we have lots and lots of experience
first let's talk about our potency
testing
every country and region that requires
the legal legalization of cannabis or
hemp requires
potency which is the determination of
the psychoactive component of
the product that you're analyzing so
delta 9 thc
it's isomer delta 8 thc must be
separated
chromatographically thca which is the
acetylenocannabinoid
and a bunch of other cannabinoids are
often uh
regulated as well these include
cannabis dialic acid can have a diol
cannabinol and can have a gerol those
are the
most commonly regulated cannabinoids
in these various regions of course most
laboratories
analyze for more at least 11 some
some labs do up to 17 or 18 or 19
of these particular uh cannabinoids
there's not a lot commercially available
so you very rarely see more than
19 or 20 cannabis in a particular method
and we first developed this on the 1220
platform the edge of the 1220 platform
which is a self-contained hplc um
and you can see it up here in the corner
and this particular version was a 400
bar with a variable wavelength detector
but lots of our customers want to do we
want to be more flexible
and so this method translates to the
1260 system
which is the mid-range modular a lot of
folks are probably more familiar
with that lc system
and we built around this on-site
consulting so the people that come and
install the instrument can also train
your laboratory so
within a few days you're up and running
and of course there's a cannabis and
hemp potency kit
that can be you know part of the
consumables that can go with this and of
course the e-method
and the consulting service that could
come with the 1220 or the 1260 lc
uh it comes with actually it's two days
of method set up now
by a trained field service engineer fse
the instruction manual the column which
is the pore shell column
the lc solvents water methanol the
the modifiers formic acid everything
that you need to get up and running
and of course trained in your laboratory
so next let's talk about pesticides and
microtoxins
which is arguably the most challenging
of all of the regulated tests um
it's challenging because sample prep is
critical
and we have a well-defined single stream
sample prep that
is amenable to both gas phase triple
quad and liquid phase triple quad
so one sample prep and that can be split
to both platforms if needed
uh here we're showing the lc triple quad
method developed by our colleague pete
stone and others
for the determination of pesticides and
mycotoxins
in flour as defined by
states where they have recreational
adult use
recreational laws for cannabis use
uh california michigan nevada oregon
washington in particular
so the target list includes compounds in
those but it can be translated pretty
much anywhere else
in the u.s and
that couples nicely with this method
here so
when you're looking at some of these
space nevada california
canada there are compounds in these
lists that are not amenable
to liquid phase and you may have heard
that yeah you can do a pci
in negative ionization mode and analyze
these on
one hardware platform and there's no
debate that you see a quantifiable
peak when you go that route the problem
is it is not selective
for certain compounds like uh
pentachloro nitro benzene in particular
and there's a there's a lot of other
problematic compounds as well captain
chlorine chlorophytopure methylperithion
in particular that just don't work well
with electrospray
or even apci so the most common approach
you'll see in
most of the laboratories especially
california some of these other states
that i mentioned
they will have both you know the lc
triple and the gc triple
and so that previous method that i just
showed you
which is on a you know tivo or 6470
lc mass spec system partners with this
on the intubo
7010 gcms ms system so
those problematic compounds you can run
as
few as five on the uh on this system
with this method or you can do more and
we do have customers that are doing more
than that so you have overlap between
the two platforms which give you
orthogonal power in terms of your data
but
this again partners well with that
previous application
and it's on the intubo uh platform so
it's a very nice small
footprint very popular and a lot of good
work went into this
we also looked at the
basically all the pesticides that are in
the u.s stateless
and in canada put them together we did
out the duplicates and came up with the
target list of 100 compounds
and from that you know from our own
experience from what you know
suggested for the analysis through
organizations like aoac
um some other tools that we have at our
disposal
this essentially said that of that list
of 100 compounds 27
of these are more amenable to gas phase
and so on our 8890 again using the 7010
uh gc triple quad mass spectrometer we
developed this uh application for 27 of
the gc minimal pesticides from that list
on this platform here and again this
here
is more pan america's so
it covers the gcm edible pesticides in
canada
the gcms amenable pesticides in the us
and so it really is something that can
translate anywhere around these two
countries so it's very
very popular and you know very robust
next of course very specific to canada
which has the largest list of 96
compounds with the lowest
action levels or limits of quantitation
many of which are around 10
ppb in the various products that they've
legalized
um we have essentially a method that is
both lc triple gc triple
uh and of course that single stream
sample prep that i described earlier
uh for specifically for canada and of
course this is the
method as well so this is pretty much
identical on the lc triple quad side uh
and very very closely
matched to the gc triple quad uh work in
the us
but this is specific to canada
we next looked at this is more recent
work
through this recent months of chaos
i would say that we at adults have not
been sitting on our hands and knees
uh we've been working we've been getting
things done we're essential business and
we've developed we've developed a very
unique and novel residual solvent
analysis
for cannabinoid products now you don't
typically do residual solvents in
plant material this is more processed
oils
wherever things have been extracted uh
with a supercritical fluid extraction
those types of things
and you want to make sure that solvents
that were used in that processing
are not left over in the product so
things like benzene or
methanol ethanol some of these common
solvents that are used for these types
of things
and so we you'll hear people say in fact
very very recently at the asms
reboot in the workshop the cannabis
works out they're talking about
residual solvents and one of the
speakers said
it's essentially usb 467 well
now we learned very quickly it is not we
really have to look at
um these cannabinoid products as
something different you know usb 467 is
very
traditional pharma single api
maybe two apis for drug-like
materials drug-like products if you're
looking at some of the
cannabinoid products hemp extracts or
cannabis extracts this
there's just not one or two
quote-unquote
api and there are active pharmaceutical
ingredient i don't call it
but active ingredient there's many
there's
lots of turf paintings that may have
properties there's of course thc
or cbd or bolt and other cannabinoids
there's flavonoids there's lots of other
uh materials in these particular things
so we quickly learned that yeah no this
is not
usp 467 and not only that
we really had to think about sample prep
it's not just weighing some material
into a headspace file
putting it on onto the auto sampler and
and analyzing it
if you really want good robust results
you have to do a little sample prep so
this
very very detailed application note here
which is a headspace
application using the intubo with the
6977d
mass spectrometer single quad mass
spectrometer um
we developed specifically for
cannabinoid products and again very
early on when you read this in fact you
can
uh in the abstract and pretty much we
say
this is not usb 467 you have to look at
it differently and so this application
does that and um very unique
we just completed liquid injection
terpene analysis on the intubo
9000 and the 5977d
and quite often you'll see in the
cannabis testing world that headspace
has been the choice
for this analysis so uh an entire space
has some advantages you don't have
matrix you don't have some of these
other things
there's a lot of disadvantages you can't
dilute uh
you lose a lot of the sesquiterpenes and
the larger
higher boiling later eluding terpenes
especially in the presence of high
cannabinoid content
so it's kind of a problematic approach
and a lot of laboratories
especially over the past year and a half
or so have really been looking for
a liquid injection approach and as what
is the first
uh vendor out there instrument vendor to
actually
have an application for this particular
and
again very very detailed a lot of work
went into this
and these applications the residual
solvents the terpenes
in tubo fast five as we call it
pesticides or the 88 90 27 pesticides
all went through an eternal vetting
process
where it's like a torture test multiple
days
multiple calibration levels everything
running replicates
and you end up with a data set of
hundreds and hundreds of data points and
then
you can look at that at intraday
intraday
statistics to calculate things like uh
the minimum detection limit mdl
or lod detection or lmq limited
quantitation
range linearity accuracy precision and
that's what we've been doing and all of
the applications that adds
us now you know releasing and you'll see
this more and more as we move forward
some new things coming
this year um that are going to go
through that vetting paradigm so
after we release them into the wild as i
like to say
we know that they're very robust
we also have a qpcr polymerase chain
reaction
right approach to uh
analyzing for e coli or aspergillus
species
these are very dangerous compounds uh
they're all regulated uh by the various
states in canada
uh you know products have to be free of
these
little buggies that can make us sick and
of course our approach
is the pcr we have partnered with
medicinal genomics
the manufacturer of the kits multiplex
kits
speciation type kits for example we now
have
with our partnership with municipal
genomics
previously when you do the multiplex
tests you look for
spec e coli aspergillus
and you can aspergillus in particular
which has four different species that
are
regulated you'd only get a positive
aspergillus you wouldn't know what
species it was
now within that same well you're gonna
get speciation
which one is it and some are more toxic
than others
so that's our partnership with um with
medicinal genomics using the aria
mx qpcr platform and
uh as opposed to plating there's a lot a
lot of advantages and
you can read the application note but
when you're when you're plating it
requires hundreds and hundreds of plates
to do these various tests for all the
samples that you might have
and here you can do you know 20 minutes
or so
all the tests you need and 96 well
plates so it's very quick very efficient
of course highly highly selective
because you're looking at specific parts
of the genome
for those particular bugs
we also have icpms for the metals the
common metals
in um they're analyzed pretty much
everywhere
lead cadmium mercury arsenic but some
other states in the us
have more antimony and some of these
others
and so we basically with our icp of 7800
icpms
system uh analyzed for the big four so
to speak
but lots of others uh 25
uh elements in a three minute test
the nice thing about this is pretty much
every sample you can think of
unlike for potency that has a different
sample prep procedure for
almost every product and pesticide safe
thing
and most of these other applications you
know they require very specific
sample prep procedures for each product
icpms uses microwave digestion
there's a very efficient way to take
pretty much any cannabis or cannabinoid
product
digest it we'll get it ready for
aspirations into the icpms for analysis
so it's very nice very fast very
efficient and is
what an analyzer to adjust
analyzer meaning that it's a product
that went through our
what we call new product introduction
quality control
2aqc type process this is you know
true agilent analyzer uh true product
built for this
application and it comes with lots of
lots of
things when you get the analyzer of
course the proven icpms
it comes with the high den density the
high matrix
interface that's required because this
is still
pretty high heavy matrix
the solution created by our experts it
reduces training costs you're up and
running in days essentially
you know it gets installed and you're
trained and you're up and running
and the um everything you need to get
started with
including the pre-configured instrument
the application module
icp go software which is software is
very specific
for the application comprehensive
implementation and assistance so get
again get up and running pre-configured
method templates
uh lots and lots of documentation so
it is something it basically makes
elemental analysis
very easy to do control your whole run
with this ic
you can see here on a on a tablet where
you're controlling your run
and you can get your results from day
one anywhere you can be anywhere
and it's compatible with the seventy
seven hundred seventy eight hundred our
ac pms
systems so that's um icpms and again
uh very very powerful a very popular
instrument for us
so in summary as one offers the complete
portfolio for cannabis testing
all of the regulated tests potency
pesticides heavy metals
terpenes residual solvents microbial
screening we have all of the tools
we have the consumables and we have
cannabis kits designed specifically for
this for the fully developed workflows
very very detailed application notes
fully vetted applications
on all of these apps these platforms
hplc
lc triple quads gc triple clouds etc
mass hunter software mostly of course
open lab software is part of the
potency application exceptional customer
service and support
and e-methods and with that
i'm going to turn it over to my
colleague
you great thanks anthony
so uh at the beginning uh anthony
mentioned that agilent's goal is to
deliver complete workflows for cannabis
analysis
and one of the new products we've
introduced
to um facilitate those complete
workflows
are chemical standards so agilent now
has a facility in rhode island
that can deliver chemical standards
both organic and inorganic reference
standards
as well as certified reference materials
for
several different markets these are all
iso certified
most products are in stock and be can be
delivered in
just a couple business days and there's
also an ability
for custom standards to be created and
delivered
so for these standards these include
instrument and column calibration as
well as systems suitability standards
there are tuning mixes for all of the
mass specs
method specific standards linearity kits
qc as well as solvent reagents
and buffers so for the cannabis
methods that anthony has been discussing
we have
a host of standards for
cannabinoid analysis these are not yet
available but they will be coming soon
you can see in the list at the bottom
there's a mixture we have mixtures for
four different cannabinoids that contain
approximately two to three standards per
mixture
these are available at one big per mill
and so if you purchase these they can be
combined together
giving you a standard at 250 micrograms
per mil
and you can use this to dilute to create
your calibration curve
get up and running very quickly we also
have
11 individual standards that can be
purchased
also at one milligram per mil and all of
these standards
are only available in the u.s and canada
so for the other methods
we have uh several standards
for pesticide analysis and currently
these cover the pesticide list for
california
nevada oregon and colorado
we will be adding additional
state-specific mixes and updating the
existing ones
to meet the 2020 guidelines soon
you can see we also have several
different mixtures of standards for
residual solvents for the gcms testing
as well as several mixtures
for terpene testing and so all of these
can be purchased
through our website
um so next i want to talk about
another new product that agilent has
introduced and these are our cannabis
kits
so currently we have cannabis kits for
uh cannabis and hemp potency as well
as pesticide and mycotoxin kits
so it can be overwhelming um
with ever-changing requirements for
cannabis potency and safety testing
in order to minimize the need for method
development
agilent has developed and compiled these
kits
and these kits include sample
preparation productions analytical
columns
as well as supplies that are needed to
identify and quantify
cannabinoids and also residual solvents
excuse me residual amounts of pesticides
and mycotoxins
so with these kits you can maximize your
productivity and uptime
they allow for one-stop shopping one
part number
gives you all of the supplies and
consumables needed
to get you up and running and start
testing and
because these kits were based off of the
application notes that anthony just
covered
they allow for easy method development
so what's in each of these kits that we
have
at the moment we have four available
with one more
coming soon so the cannabis and potency
kit will be coming soon and you can see
that we have
sample preparation supplies so these are
going to include your spe cartridges
and filters sample containment so vials
and caps
as well as lc supplies which will
include mobile phase modifiers
we also include depending on the kit
either
an lc column and gc column
as well as guard columns that are used
with these
so these kits are designed to
allow for 400 cannabis samples or hemp
samples
per kit and you can see that we have
a kit for cannabis and pesticide
mycotoxin
by ltms only and then we have
three different kits for lc and gc
combined so as anthony mentioned some
pesticides
require gcms analysis so with the kits
that have the combined lcms mgcms
you can test all pesticides
over all the lists and the kits that we
have
for these are regions specific
so uh and also platform specific so we
have
one kit designed for the gcms and tuvo
and then we have two different kits
designed for the 7890
and the 8890 one for the combined us
list and one for the canadian list
so beyond just the supplies and
consumables
that come with these kits there are also
application compendiums
that outline the potency and safety kits
and provide you with sample preparation
protocols
as well as instrument parameters that
help you start running
samples quickly and efficiently and they
also include
user guides which are kit specific
to walk you through each component
included in your kit
and these user guides also include
tips and tricks specific to the kit
so agilent is a single source for your
entire workflow
we have cannabis consumable kits
chemical standards
instrumentation software and reporting
tools
and agilent also provides service and
technical support
so from end to end agilent is able to
assist you
at any step of your cannabis analysis
so next i'd like to talk about a new
product agilent has introduced
called e-methods for the cannabis and
hemp market
and these are designed to be an
end-to-end workflow program
to quickly uh get you
up and running and assist you and help
take care of some of the method
development needs that
would normally be required to set up a
new method
so typically the steps to take before
analyzing cannabis
require a lot of work you have to
research the analysis
understand the requirements choose the
right instrument and consumables
verify your sample preparation optimize
the analytical methods
and streamline data analysis and
reporting and
this can take anywhere from weeks to
months to get
from the beginning until you're ready to
start analyzing samples
so agilent has done the work hard work
for you
we have application notes that we've
developed and taken care of all of these
steps listed
so rather than starting at the bottom of
the hill
with an e method you start eighty
percent of the way
uh and you're you can get up and running
much faster
so what is contained
in an e method so we have multiple
e-methods specific to applications
they contain extensive support
information as well as analytical
methods
and so these are designed for math
center and open lab
and the information and methods are
packaged together
into an e-method
um and this e-method can be distributed
and installed on pcs and we have
e-methods available for all of the key
applications
that anthony covered
so there are multiple components to our
e-methods
all of them are electronically delivered
they can be downloaded
from our subscribenet website that we
use for software delivery
and so they contain information about
the right instrument and configuration
optimized analytical methods for sample
introduction
chromatographic separation detection and
data analysis
they contain a list of extra expertly
selected sample preparation protocols
and consumables
best practices for sound implementation
as well as the application notes that
these are based on
so this is what our e-method software
looks like
when you load the software this window
comes up
and you can see that there is an
acquisition method
a quantitation method an example data
file
and then an additional data file and
that location where those additional
data files
can go can be user defined for the
methods and the data files these are
designed to install
into the prop appropriate math hunter
folders so that they can be
immediately loaded into the software and
used
so there's also support information
included with these e-methods
you can see there's instrument
configuration we list our software
compatibility
give background information list the
supporting files that are included
we outline sample preparation and
include purposes
and we also include a list of
consumables
including part numbers to make it easy
to find
everything needed to get up and running
um these aging e-methods as i've
mentioned the goal is to shorten
startup time and maximize profit
profitability
so with a diy approach there's a lot of
steps that are required
from when you want to get started to
when you can actually
start analyzing samples and generating
revenue
using agilent e-methods we've shortened
that
time from startup uh to analysis
and this we've also put in the time
to um verify these methods
and ensure that they work properly so
using e-methods um
you're able to get up and running faster
which can be a significant cost saving
so how will these benefit uh your
laboratory
so as i've mentioned agilent has done
the work for you we've
done the initial method development
steps and
packaged all of this information
together which can be quickly installed
and used so this
minimizes risk and effort into the
design and planning of the analysis
it eliminates delays there's no missing
or incompatible
components it can maximize profitability
by allowing for
quick startup time and it increases lab
productivity by using efficient methods
so finally i'd just like to wrap up
we have safety and quality testing
necessitates a suite of analytical
instruments
and anthony covered the different
instruments required
agilent offers a portfolio of
instruments to cover all cannabis
quality and safety testing
applications and methods have been
developed and rigorous
rigorously tested to meet all regulatory
needs
our agilent rhode island site has a
large inventory of chemical standards
and reagents
that are needed to meet cannabis lab
requirements we now offer consumable
kits
which bundle all consumables needed in
an
easy to order single part number and we
now offer suite of e-methods for fast
and easy implementation
in your lab so i'd like to thank you for
attending
uh and now we'll have a q a session
and thank you anthony and tim for that
informative presentation
and we will now start the q a portion of
the webinar
just as a reminder if you have any
questions you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask
question box located on the far left of
your screen
so let's get started we have quite a few
questions
already coming in
the first question is for you anthony
why is the terpenes analysis done
liquid injection instead of head space
okay thank you um well
if you kind of look at the history of
this this market um
initially um the approach was to
use headspace for the terpene analysis
and you would
see that you know pretty much across the
industry
but as time grew and you know the the
market matured
many laboratories realized that there
was some problems with headspace
analysis of tripping especially in the
presence of
you know high cannabinoid content
products like we're seeing today
and one of those is the loss of higher
boiling
you know heavier sesame terpenes like
apple bizabolol
and others that you begin to lose
uh as i mentioned in these heavy matrix
high cannabinoid
products and you also you can't dilute
now remember
terpenes in plant material tend to be
about one to three percent by weight so
that's
10 milligrams per gram 30 milligrams per
gram that's very very concentrated
but in some of these products you may
have much much higher content 22
30 percent of certain um
certain uh terpenes in fact in our
recent
liquid injection application that we
just completed just published last week
we looked at one of these products and
it was 22 30
so you you need to be able to dilute
that down
which you can't do with headspace and
lastly
terpenes analysis has very traditionally
been done
in the food and flavor industry by
liquid ejection
for many many many years and so with the
market trending towards lift of
injection
we felt that the time was right to get
out there
get out in front of that and get that
application for our customers
thank you anthony our next question is
for tim
how can customers access the e-methods
great thanks um so customers are will be
able to access the e-method once they've
been purchased
on our subscribenet website which
agilent already uses
for our other software delivery
customers will receive a registration
code they can sign in and create an
account
and then they'll be able to download the
e-method
directly to their computer
thank you so much and again thank you
audience for the great questions coming
in we have time for a couple more
our next question is for either one of
you are the cannabis
potency kit with the preparation
protocols
matrix specific example flour or extract
yeah i'll take that one um so
there are protocols that are provided in
the application notes now
we've divided the application out into
cannabis specific or hemp specific and
that's because of the
the laws in the u.s but the application
itself
and the preparation are the same
and it is for flower or fluorescence
um oils resins
tinctures and concentrates so we provide
you know some procedures for those
particular matrices there's many many
others i've elders
certain edibles there's gummies and
you'll see more of that uh
different matrix work come out as we
move forward
uh gummies in particular we found that
you bring them up in water sonicate and
they
melt into the solution and you can you
can take it from there so
that is the challenge with with uh many
of these
applications is the sample prep is very
specific to that particular product and
really only with
microwave digestion do you see that you
know kind of narrowed down to where
you do pretty much any product for icpms
and likely participants
thank you our next question is about the
systems
are all these systems 21 dfr
part 11 compliant
so we have compliance features that can
be turned on in the software
most laboratories that are in the
laboratories themselves
are iso 17025 compliant
and we have the ability to within our
software
turn on compliance features audit
trailing
uh those types of security issues
user levels you know super user versus a
standard user so to speak
so yeah we have that particular
um you know parts that could be turned
on in
the software i will say that many of the
labs so far
i mean they're just now the market's
just now i think starting to think about
this
part of it um as it matures but
um yeah we we have those features
thank you and thanks thank you again
both of you we have
one more question who and how create the
e
message at agilent
okay i can take that out go ahead
anthony
well we'll we'll both take this on i'll
go first uh
it is a team effort and this it begins
with the application
many of these applications have been
developed um
with my colleagues and tim and others in
the field
uh building these applications and then
bringing them in-house to
uh finish them off qualify them vet them
put them through the torture test as i
mentioned earlier
and then get it out there and then we
work with our other colleagues within
the organization
to develop the e-method tools the
software tools that go along with that
and of course we're working with our
chemistries and supplies division to
integrate their products so it really
becomes this kind of
triangle of application e-method and
consumables
all working together
and tim did you want to add to that
no i think that's a a great answer
okay perfect um anthony tim thank you
very much for this presentation did
either one of you want to provide some
closing remarks before we close today
i'd just like to say thank you to the
audience for joining us today
and feel free to follow up with us with
questions if you do reach out to me in
particular via email
and if i don't back to you really
quickly just
ping me again i get about 200 emails a
day so sometimes it's hard to
keep up with them all but i'm very happy
to answer questions after the fact
i just want to thank you both go ahead
tim go ahead
i was just going to say thanks to the to
the audience as well
and and we want to thank you both again
for your time today and for your
important research
and before we go i want to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
and remind you that questions we did not
have time for today and those submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed
by the speakers via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
through june
2021 until next time stay safe
take care bye